Julie Stout: Okay, we are recording. We are here for part 3 of my interview with Thomas Adler. My name is Julie Sout. It is March 26, 2026. I am located in Bloomington, Indiana, and Thomas Adler is still in Lexington, Kentucky.
Julie Stout: Thank you again for continuing to, let me interview you.
Julie Stout: And I want to dive in this next section of questions into specifically Richard Dawson. Again, it's based on your memories, your perspective. Feel free to share what you feel comfortable, and without further ado, I can dive right in.
Julie Stout: Awesome. Okay, so my first question for you is about your first encounters with Dawson.
Julie Stout: When and how did you first meet, and what were your earliest impressions? And no worries if you can't remember everything.
Thomas Adler: Well, I'm sure I can't remember everything, and I… undoubtedly.
Thomas Adler: saw Dawson before I ever really met him.
Thomas Adler: my… my real mentor in… in the field of folklore was Archie Green.
Thomas Adler: And Archie encouraged me to join the American Folklore Society and to come to meetings. The first meeting I came to was in Bloomington in 1968.
Thomas Adler: And… and I'm quite sure Dawson must have been there.
Thomas Adler: I don't know that I… Saw him or met him then,
Thomas Adler: so I have no memory of Dawson from that meeting. I met a lot of great folks at that meeting, including Neil Rosenberg, whom I may have mentioned to you, and
Thomas Adler: also, gosh, Mike Seeger, a bunch of musicians. We all played music in the evening after the business meetings were over, so it was… it was really fun, and I think that was one of the last
Thomas Adler: American Folklore Society meetings where everything… where you could attend the entire meeting, there were no simultaneous sessions. It was just one meeting.
Thomas Adler: And you could go to everything. So I'm sure Dawson must have been there, but I have no memory of Dawson from then.
Thomas Adler: you know, my impressions about Dawson really came from what other people said about him from
Thomas Adler: Archie, and then my professors at Cooperstown, Bruce Buckley and Rod Roberts. And, you know, they were quick to point out that… that he was a… he was primarily… he had come out of a history background. He was a historian.
Thomas Adler: And…
Thomas Adler: and was… was rather, I don't know quite how to put this. Compared with… with their views, they were… at Cooperstown, they were very much into a folklife view of the field.
Thomas Adler: Where Dawson was much more folklore into the text
Thomas Adler: View, you know, aligned that way, and was, was,
Thomas Adler: More narrowly focused on the text.
Thomas Adler: And how it would… was fit into a sense of,
Thomas Adler: historic folk literature, if I can put it that way. And so they saw, you know, they respected his work, but saw it as kind of narrower than what the field was becoming.
Thomas Adler: And, you know, that… that impression was passed on to me before… before I ever met him.
Thomas Adler: I didn't really meet him, I'm sure, until I came to Indiana. And even then, as I told you already, I didn't take those basic
Thomas Adler: Introduction to Folklore theory and techniques classes that most new graduate students at Indiana had to take, because I had already come there with an MA from Cooperstown. So,
Thomas Adler: you know, I met him, he, you know, he did various
Thomas Adler: talks, welcome talks, and things like that to the whole Folklore Institute.
Thomas Adler: So I, you know, I saw, you know, what he looked like, and sounded like, and… and like that, and there were… there were a few occasions when he would… he would speak to,
Thomas Adler: to groups of us.
Thomas Adler: And later on, you know, there were… there were meetings with him. I think I already told you that
Thomas Adler: You know, he was… He was not… Supportive of my interest in
Thomas Adler: bluegrass music, in particular, and that related to the fact that Neil Rosenberg had been powerfully interested in and… in bluegrass music, and
Thomas Adler: was a… himself a skilled performer of it, had been, in 1963, the manager of Monroe's Music Park at Bean Blossom, only 20 miles or so from Bloomington, and
Thomas Adler: Dawson had a kind of,
Thomas Adler: suspicion, I guess I'd put it, of
Thomas Adler: Of people who wanted to study something that they were already involved in.
Thomas Adler: as, as, aficionados, I think is the way he would put it, you know, or, you know, performers. And that was certainly Neil, and in a lesser way, perhaps, that was me. So,
Thomas Adler: And in the long run, that benefited me, because I already told you, he really steered Neil away from doing Neil's dissertation.
Thomas Adler: on anything that related to bluegrass music. I think that was a mistake, and eventually Dawson came to see that as a mistake, and so when it… when I…
Thomas Adler: proposed my dissertation topic, Dawson really admitted as such. He said, I didn't let Neil work on this, even though my topic was really not what Neil would have written.
Thomas Adler: But it was on Bluegrass music, and so Dorsen…
Thomas Adler: said, well, I didn't let Neil do this, and maybe that was a mistake. So, he kind of acknowledged that he had made a mistake with Neil Rosenberg.
Thomas Adler: Beyond that, I didn't work with Dorsen very much, you know? I really didn't.
Thomas Adler: I can't remember what classes or courses it took with him. You know, the courses I took, as a graduate student, you know, there were
Thomas Adler: I was interested in material culture, so there was, Warren Roberts' material culture classes. Edson Richmond, W. Edson Richmond, taught various ballad classes. Henry Glassie.
Thomas Adler: came as close as anyone to being a new mentor to me. And again, Henry was a… was,
Thomas Adler: You know, not only into material culture, but his whole interest in structural theory and… and kind of theoretical approaches to folklore.
Thomas Adler: you know, washed over me, and was… I found fascinating. I remember, you know, many,
Thomas Adler: you know, classes, you know, that Henry had at his own home, you know, and there was nothing like that close relationship with Dawson.
Thomas Adler: So…
Thomas Adler: it was… you know, Dawson was sort of aloof, you know, at least with me, because I wasn't taking his… his classes, and
Thomas Adler: I was aware that Dawson was a prodigious worker in his own right. You know, he would get up… I got the impression he got up every morning and wrote.
Thomas Adler: Hard, prodigiously, and, and, you know, was…
Thomas Adler: You know, just dedicated to writing and research himself on his historical
Thomas Adler: texts, you know, and the way he would…
Thomas Adler: We're… he… but he didn't… he didn't really supervise us.
Thomas Adler: I think he prepared his own material very assiduously, you know, to his own high standards, which were admirable, but… but he,
Thomas Adler: you know, and he was, you know, of course, Dawson's whole…
Thomas Adler: sense of folklore and fakelore. He was… he was quick to dismiss things that he didn't like as maybe fakelore, you know, and… and,
Thomas Adler: And that was, you know, there was that suspicion always on his part. So…
Thomas Adler: I… I think that… that captured Dawson in a way. He was a… he was quite a formal person, you know, it's,
Thomas Adler: I don't remember, unless he was wearing tennis togs, because he was a great tennis player.
Thomas Adler: I think he was always in a coat and tie, you know, I just… I don't remember… except when he was, you know, coming off a tennis court or something, I don't remember Dawson ever being around the Fogler Institute other than in a coat and tie.
Thomas Adler: He, he seemed… comfortable in…
Thomas Adler: the formal role of Professor Richard Dawson, you know, founder, one of the founders of the Folklore Institute, and historian and folklorist. So,
Thomas Adler: You know, he had a very,
Thomas Adler: kind of a, well, formal and slightly gruff personality, or at least that's the way we related.
Julie Stout: Did you play tennis with him?
Thomas Adler: No, I never played.
Julie Stout: Oh, okay.
Thomas Adler: As you know.
Julie Stout: We played tennis!
Thomas Adler: Probably because he played tennis a lot. It was very clear that he played tennis. He would, you know, sometimes he would come into the Folklore Institute on Fest Avenue there, you know.
Thomas Adler: Late in the day, perhaps, having played tennis, and he might be in a, you know, in shorts and a tennis sweater or something like that, but…
Thomas Adler: You know, most of the time, of course, he was… he was in… Professorial attire, you know, and…
Thomas Adler: And if… and in a classroom, it would be like the picture I sent you. That's the way I remember him looking. So,
Thomas Adler: And…
Thomas Adler: I don't know if I mentioned it, but that photo that I sent to you, I don't know what… what… when I took that, precisely. It was around 1976, so it could well have been in a meeting
Thomas Adler: you know, with Inta and the group talking about plans for the Gary gang. I can't assure you of that, because I didn't take great notes about the photo.
Thomas Adler: Then, so I don't know, but it looks like it was in a classroom. There's a blackboard or something behind him. It could have… it was around that date, around that time, but that's the way he looked to me all the time, or my memory of him.
Thomas Adler: And, oh, except… except one time, at one of the American Folklore Society meetings.
Thomas Adler: I forget which year it was. He was,
Thomas Adler: at, well, I forget which year it was, but one… one year, we were…
Thomas Adler: In whatever city it was, and there was a…
Thomas Adler: whoever was president at the time, President of the United States, was staying at the hotel, and of course, the Secret Service was all around, and they…
Thomas Adler: You know, if anyone was on the wrong floor, came out of the wrong room at the wrong time, they…
Thomas Adler: hustled them out of there, and so I remember seeing Dawson one time in pajamas in a bathrobe after the Secret Service had shooed him out of the hallway, or something like that.
Thomas Adler: But that was… that was not… you know, he didn't choose that attire, the Secret Service shoving him out of the way, you know, because you can't be here right now, sir. The president is about to come this way.
Thomas Adler: You know, not… not Dr. Dawson's choosing, you know, but
Thomas Adler: You know, but most of the time, he was… he was, you know, rather suitably attired for the occasion. That was a different
Thomas Adler: American Folklore Society meeting. That might have been in
Thomas Adler: I don't know, New Orleans, or somewhere, I forget when, which year it was. And…
Thomas Adler: I can't… I can't describe situations where I or others collaborated with Dorsen. How was it handled, and…
Thomas Adler: what to take from that experience. I don't really see him as… as collaborating. Maybe he collaborated with folks like INTA,
Thomas Adler: But most of the time, I saw him guiding things, directing things, you know, he was… he was sort of in charge of things. He was… he really saw himself as the…
Thomas Adler: the director of the Folklore Institute, and… and so I… I…
Thomas Adler: I'm sure there must have been collaboration sometimes, you know, certainly with other faculty on the Folklore Institute, but I didn't really witness that. And .
Julie Stout: I want to speak more to, like, his approach for directing, his approach as a director, whether it be personality, stuff he worked on.
Julie Stout: I don't know, just your thoughts on that.
Thomas Adler: I… I really can't speak to that.
Thomas Adler: I'm… I…
Thomas Adler: I just don't have a good memory or impression of him as a director, except that he would, you know, wherever he was, you know, he seemed to be… like, certainly in a classroom, like, where that picture was taken, he was in charge.
Thomas Adler: You know, that's… that was the impression I always had of him in a classroom.
Thomas Adler: You know, he was… It was… it was his…
Thomas Adler: his rule in that environment, you know? He was… he was the guy
Thomas Adler: directing things, at least in that moment, you know?
Thomas Adler: That was just the way it came across to me, so…
Julie Stout: What things do you like to have as a supervisor on the project?
Thomas Adler: Well, I think he was…
Thomas Adler: I… I think, you know, he… I think he was fairly free-willing as a supervisor. He tried to… to… he wasn't…
Thomas Adler: you know, he… he wanted us to go off and explore. We were all, you know, going into it, none of us, including Dorsen, I think, knew quite what we would… were in for, or what we would find, so he didn't… he wasn't trying to lead us so much, or direct us,
Thomas Adler: You know, he was…
Thomas Adler: you know, he felt we all had some experience and background, and would hopefully turn up things that… that were of interest.
Thomas Adler: That would be of interest after we were there.
Thomas Adler: But I don't think he was… he wasn't particularly directive
Thomas Adler: you know, before we went up to Gary,
Thomas Adler: Or at least I don't remember him being that way.
Thomas Adler: I think he was more, encouraging, in a sense. You know, he and Inta both.
Thomas Adler: We're like, well, we're gonna… we're gonna try to do this, you know, and see what…
Thomas Adler: what we can learn, you know, at Adler, you'll try and find these white Southerners, and Hassie, you know, how about the Black churches? And… and, March, you know, you know, how about the Croatians and
Thomas Adler: you know, other Eastern European ethnic groups that you can relate to, and… And so on, and
Thomas Adler: you know, so he was… he knew that we were a diverse group of grad students, and he was encouraging us to use what he saw as our diverse expertise, but I don't think he felt he could really
Thomas Adler: Direct us very, explicitly, because
Thomas Adler: We didn't know, and he didn't know what we'd find, you know, beforehand. So, he was encouraging,
Thomas Adler: You know, and…
Thomas Adler: I think he was positive. I don't think, going into it, that he was difficult to work with.
Thomas Adler: You know, he was… he was a complex man, but
Thomas Adler: But… but I don't think he was particularly…
Thomas Adler: hard to work with there. Again, in my own case, you know, by
Thomas Adler: by that time, you know, he had already accepted the idea that I was gonna… I was lost in the sense that I was gonna work with bluegrass music no matter what, and he had admitted that he made a mistake with… with,
Thomas Adler: Neil Rosenberg, and so he had given up on me in that respect, and acknowledged that I had some… some, some expertise or background, at least, in that direction, and that I hoped… I think he hoped I could use
Thomas Adler: profitably in going up to the Calumet region.
Thomas Adler: But…
Thomas Adler: So, but he wasn't, you know, he was positive and encouraging. He wasn't particularly difficult about any of that.
Julie Stout: He was not on your committee for your dissertation, correct?
Thomas Adler: No, he was not.
Julie Stout: Okay, yeah.
Thomas Adler: Because it was a music thing, so…
Julie Stout: thing.
Thomas Adler: Yeah, so it was Henry Glassie, Edson Richmond, Warren Roberts.
Julie Stout: Right,
Thomas Adler: you know, I forget who else, I've got a copy here somewhere, but…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: You mentioned that he's a complex man.
Thomas Adler: Yeah, I think.
Julie Stout: What does that mean to you, in your perspective?
Thomas Adler: That means he, I think he was… I said he came out of this background as a historian.
Thomas Adler: as a… You know, who saw folklore initially from a text… textual point of view.
Thomas Adler: You know, he was certainly deeply aware of folk literature as a field, but…
Thomas Adler: you know, in my education at Cooperstown, we all became very much aware of the expansion, the European expansion of folklore into what had been
Thomas Adler: begun to be called Folklife. Folk leave folklife
Thomas Adler: You know, and material culture was… was sort of alien to Dawson as a… as a direction of study for folklorists, you know?
Thomas Adler: And… you know, here, Henry Glassie had come along and joined the faculty.
Thomas Adler: And, you know, Henry's first book was Pattern in the Material Folk Culture of the Eastern United States. So Henry was a material culture guy, as well as a theoretician, in ways that Dawson didn't… didn't deal with at all.
Thomas Adler: you know, I don't think Dawson ever read Levi Strauss or anything, or if he did, it never came up.
Thomas Adler: So… but I think Dorsen was a complex guy, because he… if he didn't…
Thomas Adler: come out of that broader background of the folklife, the expansion of folklore into folklife that was going on in, you know, really through the 20th century.
Thomas Adler: He was well aware that that was happening.
Thomas Adler: And I think that that was, you know, kind of,
Thomas Adler: part of the complexity of the field for him. He was aware of it, even if it wasn't
Thomas Adler: the direction that he himself chose. He wasn't about to look into, you know, the,
Thomas Adler: Construction of, of eye houses, or, you know, patterns of, of,
Thomas Adler: you know, musical instruments or something like that. He wasn't into material culture himself as a scholar. He was still very much into
Thomas Adler: tales, and jokes, and anecdotes, and proverbs, to a degree, and…
Thomas Adler: you know, the text, the oral… oral literature, but he was, you know, he didn't reject all these things happening around him. So, in that sense, I think he was complex in that he was… he had to be aware of it all, you know?
Thomas Adler: if nothing else, just by the… the, you know, the influence of the faculty around him at the Folklore Institute, and
Thomas Adler: you know, anthropology folks and sociology folks at Bloomington. So, you know, he knew about all of that, even if it wasn't a direction that
Thomas Adler: he wanted to adopt personally. You know, he remained…
Thomas Adler: the folklorist and historian that he had been in the 40s, you know, and, you know, with Stiff Thompson, honestly.
Thomas Adler: So, I think, you know, when I call him complex, I think it was because he, you know, he was aware of all that.
Thomas Adler: but pursued, you know, in a way, the path he was on, remained true to that path, and and I think that shows up in his… in his books, even Land of the Millrats. He doesn't…
Thomas Adler: Really talk a lot about the physical
Thomas Adler: setting of… of the region, you know? I mean, he mentions it, certainly, the mills… land of the mill rats, but he's more interested in a term like that, the mill rats. That's… I think that… that's the kind of thing that would appeal to Richard Dawson, not so much the mills, you know, or the…
Thomas Adler: You know, the,
Thomas Adler: I mentioned, I think, in my essay, that, you know, someone that I had talked to talked about,
Thomas Adler: something, you know, when I was growing up in South Chicago, sometimes I would see, late at night.
Thomas Adler: Bright Lights.
Thomas Adler: To… for… to me, it was to the south of me when
Thomas Adler: The molten slag from the mills would be dumped
Thomas Adler: by these rail cars off the side of, I don't know, some kind of siding, and it would light up the sky. But in Gary, or someone I talked to said, oh yeah, we called that the Northern Lights. Well, to me, it was to the south, not north.
Thomas Adler: Because it would, you know, you'd see these… these bright lights as they dump this molten
Thomas Adler: Stuff from the mills, you know, and…
Thomas Adler: And that's, you know, terminology like that. Dawson liked terms for things, you know, and he liked names for people and things.
Thomas Adler: But I don't know if he ever ventured into the mills himself.
Thomas Adler: You know, or how many…
Thomas Adler: you know, he would like… I'm sure he would enjoy talking to mill workers.
Thomas Adler: But not on the job, probably. He would like…
Thomas Adler: To hear their stories and pick up on what they had to say and their terminology.
Thomas Adler: Because he was… he was attuned to, to oral tradition, really.
Thomas Adler: More than anything, I think.
Julie Stout: Yes, thank you, thank you, that was a very…
Julie Stout: That was an answer for more than I could have hoped for. So thank you. You may continue with the next one. I think that…
Julie Stout: I believe we're on… Number 32, which is his influence on the Dawson Gary Project, correct?
Thomas Adler: How did he directly or indirectly shape the project's aims?
Thomas Adler: our networks.
Thomas Adler: Opening doors to archives, funders, or community partners. I don't know that he did. I mean, he shaped the project's aims in this general way that I mentioned. You know, he…
Thomas Adler: you know, he and Inta… Set us all up to go do the work.
Thomas Adler: I don't know about methods or networks. He didn't open doors, that I recall, to archives funders at all.
Thomas Adler: And I don't remember him pointing us at any community partners of any kind. I mean, there was…
Thomas Adler: I don't know that, folks at…
Thomas Adler: you mentioned Indiana University Northwest, or IUPUI. I don't know that he ever directed us to… to any such resources, at the time. So…
Thomas Adler: I don't think there was any directly… direct shaping that way. He may have… he may have,
Thomas Adler: you know, tried to point into some things that way, but and I honestly don't know about funding at all.
Thomas Adler: I really don't know. That was… that was entirely hidden from me, anyway, you know, the funding.
Thomas Adler: I know somebody must have paid for those motel stays, you know, but… and bought the film that we used, but
Thomas Adler: But again, even there, they didn't… I don't… I just don't remember how that was handled.
Thomas Adler: You know, did they… You know, I don't remember how much… how much film we even…
Thomas Adler: got or used, or did we buy it, or did they buy it? Did they hand us film? Was it slides or black and white? I just don't recall those details, again, on…
Thomas Adler: you know, later on those Library of Congress projects where we had a real technological and photographic advisor, Carl Fleischauer was saying.
Thomas Adler: Not only was he saying, shoot more pictures, shoot more, shoot more, but here, take, take more, be sure to get color.
Thomas Adler: Get black and white, do more, you gotta get more film, you know, and on those projects, we sent out
Thomas Adler: The, rolls of film every night and got them back within a day or two so we could review them.
Thomas Adler: That didn't happen on the Gary project. So, again, I'm contrasting these things. I think it was… I don't know, I just don't recall how it was done on the Gary project. I don't know who paid for what things.
Thomas Adler: you know, or how it was handled, I just don't remember. INTA may know much more about that.
Julie Stout: She was able to shed some light on the NEH grant and the budget for that, and logistics.
Thomas Adler: I don't… I don't know anything about that.
Julie Stout: That is totally fine. We can definitely move to the next… next question then, which is…
Julie Stout: I actually kind of want to skip one.
Julie Stout: Oh, wait, no, I'm not skipping one, I'm going to the next one. Anecdotes. You mentioned a few things, like the funny Secret Service, like, whisking him away.
Thomas Adler: That had nothing to do with the Gary.
Julie Stout: Nothing with the Gary project, of course, but this is just on Dawson in general, so it can be beyond Gary Project.
Thomas Adler: Oh.
Julie Stout: anecdotes that illustrate what he was like to work with. I know you said he composes himself in a very professional manner, he takes his work very seriously, it seems, and…
Julie Stout: I did hear a little bit that he has a sense of humor, like, an interesting laugh, and so whatever you want to touch on.
Thomas Adler: Well, I would agree with that, that he had a sense of humor, because after that episode, again, that was totally separate from the Gary Project, but after that.
Thomas Adler: American Folklore Society meeting where the… where the Secret Service shooed him out of the way, and he was in a… in a bathrobe with his pajamas under it, and he was… you know, they had to get him out of the hallway where the president was likely to come down the hall, or something like that.
Thomas Adler: And Dawson thought that was hilarious, you know, and he… he showed people, you know, like, yeah, I was wearing this bathrobe, you know, I mean, he thought it was funny, you know, that… of course, it was out of his control, you know, I mean, it was the Secret Service, what was he gonna do? He couldn't fight with them. They were in charge of that
Thomas Adler: situation. But he… he told everyone that it had happened, you know, and… and…
Thomas Adler: you know, and here he was among all the nation's folklorists, you know, at the American Folklore Society meeting, and I think he saw… he had a good sense of humor himself, you know, and he saw the humor in that, and
Thomas Adler: And was quick to…
Thomas Adler: To… you know, he could… he could, make fun of himself, too, you know, so…
Thomas Adler: he wasn't… he could be very serious, but he wasn't, you know, without humor by any means, you know, and that… though that had nothing to do with the Gary Project, I think that illustrates that he could… he could,
Thomas Adler: see himself as an object of humor as well, you know, and he, he was,
Thomas Adler: what was he like to work with? You know, he was,
Thomas Adler: Again, once… you know, he was…
Thomas Adler: Generally serious, but he, he, he could see…
Thomas Adler: his own mistakes, as he did with Neil Rosenberg, and directing Neil away from Bluegrass, which was a mistake, and then that redounded to my benefit, ultimately. But,
Thomas Adler: Yeah, so he could… he could assess his own behavior, he could…
Thomas Adler: make light of his own situation, as he did with the pajamas and the bathrobe and the Secret Service. He had a sense of humor. What was he like to work with? Mostly, you know, on a professional basis, mostly serious.
Thomas Adler: you know, as you would expect of the professor and director of the Folklore Institute. But,
Thomas Adler: You know, serious and commanding as a presence.
Thomas Adler: But not… not one-dimensional, ever, you know? He was… he… he was…
Thomas Adler: you know, he loved his tennis game, he had a sense of humor, I think he got along well with the other faculty members, and he was…
Thomas Adler: You know, he was never… I never saw him…
Thomas Adler: Even when he wanted to steer graduate students like me in… into or away from some particular direction, I never saw him be, insulting or demeaning.
Thomas Adler: He, he was… he was always…
Thomas Adler: You know, professorial and respectful that way.
Thomas Adler: Again, even when he grudgingly gave me permission to do a dissertation that dealt with bluegrass.
Thomas Adler: He acknowledged his mistake with Neil.
Thomas Adler: and let me move forward. So, you know, he was… in that sense, he was… complex, and…
Thomas Adler: professional and interesting, and he was… he was a… he was quite a fascinating human being, you know, is all I can say.
Thomas Adler: Dawson was a… You know, there'll never be another man like him.
Julie Stout: Which leads me into my very last question for you, which is about legacy and reassessment.
Julie Stout: How has your view of Dawson's contributions
Julie Stout: evolved over time. And what should students and future researchers understand about his impact and the complexities of his legacy?
Thomas Adler: I think they should see… That he was… that he… he… was… A folklorist and historian who…
Thomas Adler: In his own career, moved from the…
Thomas Adler: earliest phases of American folklore study into…
Thomas Adler: He was always professional, but he moved into a broader understanding of what the field
Thomas Adler: had become and was becoming. That it had broadened, even if it wasn't… even if its greater breadth
Thomas Adler: contained areas that didn't always personally appeal to him in the sense of things he wanted to devote his time and scholarship on.
Thomas Adler: he understood That… that folklore… As, as a field, was, was, bigger.
Thomas Adler: And I think future researchers should see
Thomas Adler: Dawson's impact, for one thing, as significant because of, if nothing else, the sheer volume of his research and writing, which was enormous, and
Thomas Adler: And the complexity of his legacy is that he understood
Thomas Adler: you know, that there were new areas to move into, like urban folklore. Even if he didn't quite know
Thomas Adler: How to approach it himself, you know, the whole idea of
Thomas Adler: is there… moving from, is there a folk in the city, to, let's take a group, or not direct a group of graduate students, but let's send a group of graduate students into a complicated urban area. That's a demonstration of his growth and impact
Thomas Adler: you know, through his career. And,
Thomas Adler: And so I think people should see Dawson's overall trajectory as one of
Thomas Adler: Of constant change and growth,
Thomas Adler: And you can see some of that… some of that in his published works.
Thomas Adler: And even more of it through his
Thomas Adler: his legacy, at IU, and… and the Folklore Institute, and his students.
Julie Stout: And on that note, anything else you'd like to add about Richard Dawson? Anything else you'd like to share?
Thomas Adler: I can't think of anything.
Julie Stout: There you go! And thank you so much for your time again, and I will end this one here.
Thomas Adler: Happy to help.